hey guys run right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching a spider thawne
spider-man Athan something like that so
who would have thought you know they
suddenly released another clip of the
amazing spider-man 2 they harian electro
one um it's about [__] time because
we do not get enough of these we need
more and more clips on the daily like I
said
final trailer but they're like here's 10
more scenes for you I found out there's
a pretty cool-looking international
trailer number and I really want to
watch that too so without further ado
the amazing spider-man 2 Harry and
electro
you're bleeding I'm gonna get you
all right but we don't have much time
Oh Harry Osborn I wanna make you a deal
it's for you it looks really cool but it
was kind of funny when he was like
another good clip not much more you keep
saying about these clips other than the
fact that they all look you know pretty
[__] good don't know why electro
wants to kill Harry and that makes you
go I gotta watch this movie to find out
why the [__] electro said I should kill
you every voice I do becomes Bette and
now ladies and gentlemen the
International trailer number Oh
despite the magnetic of the language
that is this is awesome
let's look at the way it's shot either
one
I wonder what the [__] is being said
right now I prefer to watch it in this
language
with no subtitles for the stuff in
Neurology typical of the Roman
occupation
Peter this language
Wow man green Bobby's really back
happiness in kill Gwen Stacy
weird the power windows errors on the
spider-man
don't know what that was
amazing spider-man 2 w-wait a minute
sorry I love you
hello
that looks so good this is eat I didn't
understand what they were saying
except for beat doc I don't know even
what language it is I'm just making fun
of the country's accent right now that
is yes yes yes yes yes yes
is what the ladies say what I'm Ryan is
a mime in them I'm not beating them hi n
there's a sex reference anyway my segue
into subscribe please
so yeah um it's a good thing to
subscribe now a special person a man
requests it that's when I watch this
clip finally god I will give him said
shoutout Robby Owens Shannon orange
green girl I remember you being awesome
and then you got a little bit of selling
me over my April Fool's Day video maybe
because you get to see my ass in it
that's true for all you people haven't
seen it yet check out that short film
totally see my bare ass it's awesome
listen pubes I'm not even joking
Diablo xxx nine hundred or whatever your
name is I think I got it right ah dude
you want a shout-out
so here it is buddy what do you say to
shadow play want to talk to my special
boy out there Diablo xxx 900 or 90 can't
remember his name but he's the [__]
homie apparently that's what I think is
shout out should be like